this video is sponsored by blinkist
things are either devolving toward or
evolving from nothingness
Leonard Corin
cracks on a plate a stain on a couch a
room slightly Askew a wrinkle on a face
for most of us these things are to be
avoided replaced or at the very least
they're less than desirable we turn away
from signs of imperfection of damage of
impermanence we yearn for the ideals the
symmetrical and Youthful the Timeless
and undamaged the absolute and perfect
Western tradition wields reason and
order as its choice of weapons in the
war against the universe so-called laws
and truths from battles.1 hang over its
mantle ideals burn in its hearth but
this fire requires constant feeding and
it is always on the brink of burning out
collectively and individually for many
of us it already has the hope that
anything may be discovered or obtained
that will make the coldness of the
universe go away has been lost for
others of us perhaps we've been engulfed
by the fire burning ourselves up with
Relentless desire
for those looking to better deal with
the hot and cold of existence who might
struggle with impossible goals or
Perfection certainty and permanence one
idea that is tremendously useful is the
Japanese concept known as wabi-sabi
in the 12th century a Japanese Buddhist
monk named nonan created the first
independent Zen Buddhist School in Japan
this formally introduced ideas and
principles from Chan Buddhism to the
Japanese World Central to Buddhism is
the idea that suffering is an inevitable
part of existence more specifically
suffering arises out of the tension
between our desire and the nature of
reality we desire things like permanence
Perfection and certainty but the
universe which we are inextricably a
part of is in constant flux subject to a
process of change transience and
imperfection
as a result of Zen's introduction and
development in Japan over time this
transient and imperfect condition of
reality would soon be uniquely viewed as
an ally to meditate on and make peace
with rather than an enemy to contend
against by around the 15th century two
terms would come together to embody this
View and become a central part of
Japanese culture Aesthetics and
philosophy
together these terms are wabi-sabi
although there is no direct English
translation wabi-sabi essentially
describes the view or experiences where
Beauty and virtue are found in the
impermanent imperfect and incomplete
from an aesthetic point of view
wabi-sabi values what is visually
incomplete worn damaged unsymmetrical or
minimalistic artwork that is considered
wabi-sabi often emphasizes the process
as opposed to the end result and
moreover the end result is often
maintained and used past the point in
which it still appears fresh new or
undamaged visual artist Richard Powell
said wabi-sabi nurtures all that is
authentic by acknowledging three simple
realities nothing lasts nothing is
finished and nothing is perfect
for example a popular style of Japanese
pottery that follows the principles of
wabi-sabi is known as Raku Pottery this
style of pottery is often hand shaped
fired at low temperatures and left to
cool in the open air resulting in Porous
inconsistent and uniquely shaped vessels
this outcome and process intentionally
puts an emphasis on Simplicity and
naturalness
another Japanese practice known as
kinsugi involves the repairing of broken
pottery by covering the cracked areas
with powdered gold silver or platinum
mending the vessel back together the
mended cracks are intentionally left
prominent viewed as beautiful enhanced
parts of the piece
through both Raku and kinsuki practices
the imperfect and damaged aspects of the
ceramic wear are seen as beautiful
positive portrayals of the natural
experience of existence
[Music]
from a more philosophical view mirroring
its Aesthetics wabi-sabi values living
simply finding peace in the
temporariness of all things and
embracing what is flawed and incomplete
in nature life and oneself
signs of these things and ways of living
in harmony with them represent a more
honest and useful idea of perfection the
Perfection of imperfection for example
around the 13th to 15th century Japanese
tea ceremonies were popularly used by
the ruling class of Shoguns as a way of
displaying wealth using extravagant
ceramic wear to sip tea inside of
lavishly ornamented rooms under a full
moon in 1488 however Zen monk Morata
shuko would redefine the Tea Ceremony
based on principles of wabi-sabi it
would soon become customary for the Tea
Ceremony to be conducted using simple
ceramic wear produced by Japanese
Artisans often using Raku or kinsugi
practices and the tea would be sipped
while sitting in minimalistic settings
under partial moons or cloudy night
skies the Japanese tea ceremony would
become a worship of the simple and
imperfect
[Music]
although there are seemingly key
attributes to things that we find
beautiful there are also ways of
thinking and seeing things that create
beauty beauty is not merely based on
what things we are perceiving but how we
are perceiving things a phenomenon
contingent on the mind
if we wish to see more Beauty in life as
life really is it is thus up to us to do
so
wabi-sabi offers a lens through which we
can more easily do this a way to more
frequently experience Beauty in and
derive peace from the true conditions of
reality
Beauty writes artist Leonard Corin can
be coaxed out of ugliness wabi-sabi is
ambivalent about separating Beauty from
non-beauty or ugliness the beauty of
wabi-sabi is in one respect the
condition of coming to terms with what
you consider ugly wabi-sabi suggests
that beauty is a dynamic event that
occurs between you and something else
Beauty can spontaneously occur at any
moment given the proper circumstances
context or point of view beauty is thus
an altered state of consciousness an
extraordinary moment of poetry and Grace
there's nothing inherently wrong with
continually striving for something
closer to perfection but in truth the
distance between good and perfect is
infinite
wabi-sabi reminds us to not depend on
ever finally arriving it reminds us
rather that the process is part of the
results that the beauty of things is
largely in our mind and that nothing in
nature is perfect complete or permanent
and if nature can't make it that way why
would we think we can
on one hand wabi-sabi refers to and
describes an important part of Japanese
history and culture but on the other it
refers to a philosophical idea an
aesthetic experience deeply relevant to
us all
everything we try will fail in some way
everything we finish will be some amount
incomplete everything we know everything
we cherish everything that works right
now will Decay fall apart and disappear
back into nothingness this is something
we almost contend with we can thrash
against and resist it which naturally
and inevitably we will but we can also
try our best whenever possible to accept
this reality to find the beauty and
virtue within it and learning to embrace
things as they are not how we want them
to be in every crack on a plate staying
on a couch wrinkle on a face roam
slightly Askew we can see beauty we can
see truth we can see the Oneness of
nature that connects all things
in the words of David Foster Wallace if
you're automatically sure that you know
what reality is and you are operating on
your default setting then you like me
probably won't consider possibilities
that aren't annoying and miserable but
if you really learn how to pay attention
then you will know there are other
options it will actually be within your
power to experience situations as not
only meaningful but sacred on fire with
the same force that made the Stars love
Fellowship the mystical Oneness of all
things deep down not that that mystical
stuff is necessarily true the only thing
that's capital T true is that you get to
decide how you're going to try to see it
wabi-sabi may not be everyone's taste
and moreover arguably even for those for
whom it is no one can ever totally
Embrace imperfection impermanence or
incompleteness but perhaps in our own
imperfect abilities to ever fully
Embrace imperfection we are in a way
nonetheless still embodying the idea of
wabi-sabi perfectly
this video was sponsored by blinkist if
you're interested in learning more about
Japanese philosophy culture and history
or perhaps more about Buddhism and other
Eastern philosophies blinkist is a
fantastic enjoyable way to do so blinkus
is an app that allows you to discover
and understand the most important
insights from over 5 500 non-fiction
books and podcasts across 27 different
categories all in just 15 minutes
blinkist even has curated collections to
help make it even easier to discover new
books that you're interested in and
better organize your learning process
for example one collection called the
Japanese way contains an assortment of
incredible books covering various
Japanese approaches to different areas
of life one great title in particular
within this collection is Ika guy by
Hector Garcia and Francesca Marias which
explores the Japanese concept of ikigai
an approach toward happiness and
longevity in life centered around
purpose-driven activity low stress and
diet and exercise blinkist helps break
down and explain Key insights from the
book so you can better discover your own
or reason for being and now with blinker
spaces you can easily create a specific
space where you can add share and
recommend titles like this one with
friends and family create a space around
a specific group of friends with whom
you share similar interests or around a
topic that you want everyone in your
life to learn more about blinkist makes
it easy to discover new books and
authors refresh yourself on books you've
read and accelerate your learning
process in general click the link in the
description or scan the QR code on the
screen and you'll receive a seven day
free trial and 25 off an annual premium
subscription
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]